T, RUSSIAN TROOPCUPIED A NUCLEA
IN C HAVE
EXPOD CA
RADIATION.ND RELEASED HE
INTERNALS AND BONEARW.
DEATH.KEIEONT.WE KNOW ABOUT THI
PIECES TOGR
IMAGESG IN TBER THE
CHERNOBYD HUH THE RUSSIANSVEG
STAGE.W, MORE DES  IN.
APPARENTACCOINENIERS IGGING PUT
THIS IS  TLUONE AREA AROUNNOBYRT
AFTER ITS KIND IHI
SAW FALL OUTREACTORSND IF THEY
EXPERTS BELIEVE THEY
LEVELS OF RADIIO
SO, THE RUSSPA.ING THE LAST
THAVE BEEN LEAVINGVEE
R UKRAINIA
BUT UNCLEERP H SICK IF AT SOLDI
CRITICISM ON THE AROUND CLEAR R
AND THE HEAD OF TH
ENER AY TEN THERE
MAY HAVE BN  IN TH
HOUSE OF E ARMOR.TE HAVE COME
KIND OCKNESS FE SOLDIERS IN TH
THEMO SAYS HE IS TAT ZONE AS SO
POSSIB INVESTE?
>> T VY MUCH.
THIS IS SOMETHING  Y
THEY FIRST CAME TO
SO THE MAIN TREATMENT LINE WE H
IT'S CHERNOBYL.
BUNOW WE'RRE D ES POSSIBLY.
WH REACTIOWHENHEAR TS?
NCREDISSNESS OR  OUPITN BE SO
CAVALIERBO S AREA CHERNOTO
TROOPS TO DIRIDICULOUS.
FA M SHOWS BLE THESACES
ARE,ABLYVEHERNOBYL, E THE SHIEL.
I HAVE BEEN CONCERNE
R  OHE
ERRANT BOM ES MISSE,NG, AN
WE WOULDR ON
OUR HAND
TREDUCATION, AME CASES, THERARS
SOME OF THE KIDS DIDN'T UNDERS W
THE MEANING OF THAT
K IT
LEL  SICK AS
DISREGARD FOR RUSSPSAPPARENTLY
EXPENDABLE. TF THING
UNDOUBTTEN
AROUND AMONG
THE LET VERY G